spacex has recently been making rapid
progress with their new prototype rocket
starship in fact with the recent s9
launch
if you look closely you can actually
spot sn10 waiting to be launched next
clearly spacex has been pumping out
starship after starship and at this
point
it actually seems like the regulation
and testing process is their main
bottleneck
as opposed to the actual construction
process so
how does spacex manage to develop and
build starship rockets so quickly
well starting off the first major
obstacle when it comes to building a
rocket
is sourcing funding we don't know if
spacex is actually profitable themselves
as they don't release their financial
reports like public companies
it's possible that they are in a
position where they can choose
profitability
however i suspect they take all the
profits from commercial launches
and put it back into research and
development considering that spacex is
by far the most popular commercial
launch provider
it's likely to divert a lot of these
profits to starship
aside from internal profitability spacex
has spent nearly two decades at this
point proving their ability to innovate
and their reliability as a result it's
very easy for spacex to raise more money
whenever they need
just last week reports suggested that
spacex raised another 850 million
dollars
with a massive valuation of 74 billion
something else to keep in mind is that
the founder and majority stakeholder is
of course elon musk
who is hovering between richest and
second richest person in the world
so investors into spacex really don't
have to fret about spacex going bankrupt
worst case scenario elon will just go
ahead and liquidate a bunch of tesla
shares to keep spacex afloat
as you can see spacex may be profitable
themselves
they have a proven track record and they
have massive investor credibility
thus for all realistic purposes they
have unlimited funding power
but just because they have so much
funding doesn't mean that they are
careless with it
and that brings us into spacex's choice
of material with starship
for the entirety of our space
exploration history virtually all major
rockets have used aluminum
titanium or some sort of carbon
composite this was originally going to
be the case with starship
as well but at the beginning of 2019
spacex decided that stainless steel was
actually a better choice for a variety
of reasons
starting with of course cost elon musk
explains that carbon fiber costs 135
dollars per kilogram
and unfortunately 35 of that is usually
wasted in the construction process
so each kilogram of carbon fiber that
ends up making its way onto the final
rocket
actually cost upwards of 200 meanwhile
stainless steel only cost three dollars
per kilogram
aside from the obvious cost savings this
is extremely beneficial
because it allows spacex to experiment
much more freely
instead of running simulations on a
computer where unknown variables don't
play a factor
spacex can go ahead and just run a real
live pressure test till failure
evidently the extremely cheap material
choice allows spacex to run more tests
collect more real data and rapidly
improve as mistakes don't cost them an
intolerable amount
moving on stainless steel is also much
more durable than carbon fiber elon musk
revealed that aluminum
and carbon fiber are generally able to
withstand 150 to 180 degrees celsius
you might be able to push it to 200
degrees celsius but that's generally the
limit
with stainless steel on the other hand
must suggest that it is capable of
temperatures
up to 120 to 870 degrees celsius this is
again
quite important as rockets need to be
able to handle very high
and very low temperatures during flight
moreover if you guys remember
one of the most serious issues with
constructing and refurbishing the space
shuttle was the heat shield
every single heat shield tile had to be
individually inspected and repaired
this was especially time intensive and
tedious because the space shuttle had
over 21 000 heat shield tiles
conversely since starship's exterior
itself is much more capable of higher
temperatures
spacex doesn't have to pay nearly as
much attention towards heat concerns
elon musk has even suggested that
transpiration-based cooling may be
enough to keep starship cool
in such a system starship would have two
exterior stainless steel layers
and water or cooling liquid would flow
between the two sandwich layers
this system is no doubt much easier than
installing thousands of heat shield
towels
which brings down the construction time
quite substantially
next up we have spacex's actual
construction process itself
usually rockets are constructed in
extremely clean environments with large
dedicated machinery that takes care of a
lot of the work
though this is quite helpful this also
adds a lot of work
engineers not only have to design and
maintain the rocket itself
but they also have to design and
maintain a machine that builds a rocket
similarly the rocket company will not
only have to fund the rocket itself
but also the machines that assemble and
construct various rocket parts
with starship however this is not the
case spacex doesn't use large molding
machines or huge 3d printers to produce
parts for starship
really the production process is just
making a bunch of stainless steel rings
a couple of flaps and the nose cone and
as for the construction
most of the construction takes place in
broad daylight exposed to all of the
elements
prototypes often endure rain high winds
and even tropical storms as boko chica
is right next to the ocean
also aside from the massive cranes are
used to move and lift components there's
absolutely no fancy machinery
it's literally just a bunch of guys
welding together stainless steel rings
out in the open
spacex doesn't even take advantage of
spiral welding because the exterior wall
of starship
isn't uniformly thick so spacex spacex's
straight-up launcher prototypes that are
hand welded together
though there are some safety concerns
regarding this construction process as
it is thus far unclear how durable these
rockets are
this rudimentary production and
construction process know that cuts down
overall manufacturing time
significantly another major method
spacex utilizes to shorten development
and manufacturing time
is iteration spacex has been a huge fan
of the iterative design process
and this has saved them insurmountable
time here's the thing
most companies in any industry will
segment out the development process
for instance if we're looking at the
airline industry boeing will first go
ahead and fully design an airplane
this process often takes years next
they'll construct it
test it and fix any issues if everything
goes well
they'll mass produce it and sell it to
the airlines maybe a few years later
they'll go back and modify certain
things about the airplane and created
version 2
and version 3 and so on and so forth
between each of these versions though
every single airplane that comes out of
boeing is identical with spacex on the
other hand
no two rockets they produce are
identical spacex doesn't try to get a
perfect on the first try
and they definitely don't wait to make
future iterations until they get it
perfect
with starship spacex has taken this
philosophy to the next level
they think of a design they put it
together as fast as possible
and they launch if it works that's great
they'll focus on how to make it even
better
if it doesn't work that's fine too they
didn't spend too much time and manpower
on the launch
anyways by employing this aggressive
development process
spacex is able to rapidly filter through
what works and what doesn't work
musk has confessed that this
occasionally results in massive setbacks
for the company
however he has also suggested that
spacex is willing to tolerate such
losses
in order to embrace the iterative design
process once starship becomes a
commercial rocket that people actually
use on a regular basis
spacex will no longer be able to use
this approach as the stakes would be too
high
considering this spacex is determined to
take full advantage of the iterative
process
while they still can and a plethora of
prototypes is simply a byproduct
of this approach anyways before we get
to the final
and most significant factor driving
forward starship development we have one
more smaller reason
which is competition now i understand
that spacex is way ahead of the
competition
however i think a major reason for that
is the actual existence
of competition nasa has stagnated for
decades
and one of the key reasons for this is
that the us is no longer competing
against russia
i know many of you guys think blue
origin is a joke but really
jeff bezos is not a joke by any means he
built one of the largest
and most successful companies in the
world amazon
and now he's stepping down to fully
focus on blue origin
considering this android plans with new
glenn i wouldn't fully write off the
competition
just yet but more than all of these
reasons
the primary reason spacex is able to
build starships so quickly
is because they're on a constant time
crunch the truth is
elon musk is running out of time and i'm
not talking about running out of funding
or losing commercial customers to blue
origin
or anything business related rather elon
musk is actually running out of lifetime
hopefully we all live into our 80s and
90s and even past 100
but life is unpredictable and elon musk
is already about to turn 50 this summer
it took spacex nearly 20 years just to
get people to the international space
station
and though that is an outstanding
achievement there's still so much work
left in actually getting to mars
at this rate mars is simply not going to
happen within his lifetime
elon musk has even gone on record
stating that this is what concerns him
most well the thing that the thing that
concerns me most right now is that
unless we improve our rate of innovation
dramatically then there is no chance of
a base on the moon
or a city on mars not i'll be like
yeah this is my biggest concern with
that being said
elon musk is genuinely concerned that
spacex won't make it within his lifetime
as a result he's willing to do anything
that's not illegal or puts people in
danger
to expect the development process if
that means building a plethora of
prototypes by working 24 7
and blowing several of them up during
testing that's completely fine
at this point the only things that
matter to him are the rate of innovation
at spacex
and safety nothing else though that is a
rather dark source of motivation
the fear of death is a very powerful
force and this
likely plays a strong role in starship's
rapid development process
in the end there are several objective
factors that are pushing forward
starship development
at unprecedented rates spacex has wisely
chosen a great material
crafted a simple construction process
and they have employed an aggressive
development strategy
on top of this they also have
essentially unlimited funding and
respectable competition nudging them
forward
but the biggest factor launching
starship development to mars is that
elon musk is on time crunch
and he is determined to reach mars
before it's too late
when do you guys think spacex will reach
mars comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys hope that
elon musk will be able to fulfill his
dream
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest for your
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions i'll just answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]
you